It may be a little hard to remember now, but when Donald Trump announced he was officially running for president again this time around, he did not seem inevitable-- far from it.
现在可能有点难回想起来了，但当唐纳德·特朗普宣布他这次正式竞选总统时，他看起来并非势不可挡——事实远非如此。
It was a week after the midterm elections where the Trumpiest candidates lost some key races. Polls showed Governor Ron DeSantis beating him for the Republican nomination. He had very few endorsements from other Republican politicians. Jonathan Karl covered Trump's announcement for ABC News, where he's Chief Washington correspondent.
那是在中期选举之后的一周，当时特朗普最力挺的候选人在几场关键竞选中落败。民调显示，罗恩·德桑蒂斯州长在共和党提名中领先于他。他几乎没有得到其他共和党政客的支持。乔纳森·卡尔为美国广播公司新闻部报道了特朗普的声明，他是该部的华盛顿首席记者。
I mean, I was at Mar-a-Lago. It was a really flat speech. First of all, it was teleprompter Trump. He was reading from the teleprompter. And there was no fire and brimstone to it. It was kind of warmed over policy proposals. It was flat.
我的意思是，当时我在海湖庄园。那场演讲真的很平淡。首先，那是用提词器演讲的特朗普。他在照着提词器念。演讲中没有那种雷霆万钧的气势。就像是热了又热的政策建议。很平淡。
But we will bring our supply chains and manufacturing base back home, as we were strongly doing during the Trump administration. And we will systematically--
但我们将把供应链和制造业基础带回国内，就像我们在特朗普执政期间大力做的那样。我们将系统性地——
People tried to leave the room. I mean, I was there in Mar-a-Lago. I saw people going to the exits halfway through the speech. And at one point, there were so many people leaving that they actually blocked the exits. They told me it was for security reasons. But I don't think he wanted a half-empty Mar-a-Lago ballroom at the conclusion of his presidential announcement.
人们试图离开房间。我是说，我当时就在海湖庄园。我看到演讲进行到一半时，有人走向出口。一度有太多人离开，以至于他们实际上堵住了出口。他们告诉我是出于安全原因。但我认为他不希望在总统竞选声明结束时，海湖庄园的宴会厅半空着。
So, not a great beginning. When did it turn around? Jonathan says that began with the speech that Trump gave a few months later, in March 2023, at the annual CPAC conference of conservatives. It was a very different speech with a very different tone.
所以，这不是一个好的开始。什么时候发生了转机？乔纳森说，这始于特朗普几个月后，即2023年3月，在保守派年度CPAC大会上发表的演讲。那是一场非常不同的演讲，语调也大不相同。
It's really dark, and it is filled with talk about getting, essentially, revenge at those who have wronged him.
演讲基调非常阴暗，充斥着关于本质上要向那些冤枉他的人复仇的言论。
Democrat prosecutors-- oh, they're after me for so many things. Oh, those prosecutors. Some are racists. Some hate our country. They all hate me. They'll get me for anything, anything. "You put a comma in this paragraph. Why did you do that?" I don't really know.
民主党检察官——哦，他们因为这么多事情紧追我不放。哦，那些检察官。有些是种族主义者。有些仇视我们的国家。他们都恨我。他们会为了任何事情抓我，任何事情。“你在这段里加了个逗号。你为什么要这么做？”我真的不知道。
This is the famous speech where he said, "I am your retribution."
这就是那场著名的演讲，他在演讲中说：“我就是你们的报应。”
In 2016, I declared, I am your voice. Today I add, I am your warrior, I am your justice. And for those who have been wronged and betrayed, I am your retribution. I am your retribution.
2016年，我宣布，我就是你们的声音。今天我补充说，我就是你们的战士，我就是你们的正义。对于那些曾经被冤枉和背叛的人，我就是你们的报应。我就是你们的报应。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
And that line, obviously, stuck out in the speech itself. But then speaking to Steve Bannon afterwards--
显然，那句话在演讲本身中脱颖而出。但后来与斯蒂夫·班农交谈时——
Steve Bannon, former Trump advisor, still apparently talks to him.
斯蒂夫·班农，前特朗普顾问，显然仍在与他交谈。
--he said that was the pivotal moment in the campaign that the campaign got its mojo. And he kept on calling it the Come Retribution speech.
——他说那是竞选活动的关键时刻，竞选团队找回了状态。他一直把它称为“报应来临”演讲。
Come Retribution, Bannon explained to Jonathan, was reference to a book about a supposed plot by the Confederacy to kidnap and maybe kill Abraham Lincoln. The plan was code named Come Retribution because it was revenge.
班农向乔纳森解释，“报应来临”是参考了一本关于南部邦联据称阴谋绑架甚至可能杀害亚伯拉罕·林肯的书。该计划的代号为“报应来临”，因为它是一场复仇。
I don't think that Bannon is calling for the assassination of Trump's political opponents or anything like that. But he is calling for-- and Trump is calling for-- an effort to get even with these people, to make them pay for their transgressions, their transgressions being crossing Donald Trump.
我不认为班农是在呼吁暗杀特朗普的政治对手或类似的事情。但他确实是在呼吁——特朗普也在呼吁——一场向这些人报复的努力，让他们为自己的过错付出代价，而他们的过错就是冒犯了唐纳德·特朗普。
Weeks after that speech, former President Trump held his very first official campaign rally for the new campaign-- kind of a big moment. It was not in a swing state or any place that he needed to pick up votes. The location he chose-- Waco, Texas.
在那次演讲几周后，前总统特朗普为新一轮竞选举行了他第一次正式的竞选集会——这算是一个大时刻。地点不在摇摆州，也不在他需要争取选票的地方。他选择的地点是德克萨斯州韦科。
Now, I've been covering presidential campaigns for a long time. And presidential announcements, they often are weighted in symbolism-- Barack Obama in Springfield. He decides to have it in Waco, Texas. Waco, Texas, of course, is the place where the Branch Davidians, David Koresh, had their standoff with federal agents in 1993.
我报道总统竞选很长时间了。总统候选人的声明通常带有象征意义——巴拉克·奥巴马在斯普林菲尔德。他决定在德克萨斯州韦科举行。德克萨斯州韦科，当然，是大卫教派领袖大卫·考雷什在1993年与联邦特工发生对峙的地方。
This, of course, ended in disaster. The place went up in flames. 75 people died.
这当然以灾难告终。那个地方燃起了大火。75人死亡。
It is the symbol for the far-right of a government that is out of control and is a threat to its own citizens. So here is the place that Donald Trump goes to have his very first rally. When I asked Bannon about it, I was like, come on, Waco? What is going on here? He said, what do you mean? We are the Trump Davidians.
对于极右翼来说，这是政府失控并威胁其自身公民的象征。所以这就是唐纳德·特朗普举行他第一次集会的地方。当我问班农这件事时，我说，拜托，韦科？这到底是怎么回事？他说，你什么意思？我们就是特朗普的“大卫教派”。
We laughed, but there was clearly a message being sent. The federal government was out of control. The deep state was out of control when the Branch Davidians were raided, and the result was a bloodbath. Once again, they are out of control. This time they're going after Donald Trump and his MAGA supporters.
我们笑了，但显然传递了一个信息。联邦政府失控了。当大卫教派被突袭时，“深层政府”失控了，结果是一场大屠杀。他们再次失控了。这一次，他们是在针对唐纳德·特朗普和他的“让美国再次伟大”（MAGA）支持者。
And what you saw on stage when the rally started, did it seem appropriate to the setting and to that context?
当集会开始时，你在台上看到的场景，它与那个环境和背景相符吗？
It was so remarkable. And a lot of people-- people didn't really note it much because we're early in the presidential campaign cycle, I mean long before people were actually going to be voting.
这太引人注目了。很多人——人们并没有太注意到它，因为我们还在总统竞选周期的早期，我是说在人们真正投票之前很久。
But it started with Donald Trump coming out on stage silently, as the speakers started blaring the national anthem performed by a group called the J6 Choir, the J6 Choir being people who are in a DC prison for alleged crimes related to January 6, allegedly assaulting police officers, breaking into the Capitol building.
但开场是唐纳德·特朗普默默地走上舞台，同时扬声器开始播放由一个叫“1月6日合唱团”的团体演唱的国歌，“1月6日合唱团”是那些因与1月6日有关的涉嫌犯罪——据称袭击警察、闯入国会大厦——而被关在华盛顿特区监狱的人。
And Trump, as this is playing out, is standing on stage, hand over his heart. And the scenes on the screens behind Trump are the images of the assault on the US Capitol on January 6. Again, we're in Waco, Texas.
特朗普在播放国歌时，手放在胸口站在台上。特朗普身后屏幕上的画面是1月6日袭击美国国会大厦的影像。再说一次，我们在德克萨斯州韦科。
One nation under God.
在上帝的庇护下，合而为一的国家。
(SINGING) O say does that star-spangled--
（演唱）哦，你说那星条旗是否——
Donald Trump spoke for an hour and a half, and most of it was the kind of stuff you'd expect-- how Joe Biden's running down the country, how great things were when Trump was president. He talked about inflation and China and the fake news media. But over and over, through the speech, and in his speeches since, he lectured about how the government under Joe Biden is out to get you.
唐纳德·特朗普演讲了一个半小时，大部分都是你预料之中的内容——乔·拜登如何搞垮国家，特朗普当总统时事情有多棒。他谈到了通货膨胀、中国和假新闻媒体。但演讲中，以及他之后的演讲中，他一遍又一遍地讲授在乔·拜登领导下的政府是如何针对你们的。
The Biden regime's weaponization of law enforcement against their political opponent is something straight out of the Stalinist Russia horror show. Let there be no doubt the injustices being done, not only to me but to dozens across our country, will not stand. And we're not going to stand for it.
拜登政权将执法部门武器化以对付他们的政治对手，这是斯大林统治下的俄国恐怖秀才会有的东西。毫无疑问，不仅是对我，而且是对我们全国几十个人所实施的不公正行为，是不会长久的。我们绝不会忍气吞声。
It's the heart of his speech. It's the core of his message. The government is out of control. It is out to get you. I'm the guy standing in the way. That's why I'm being prosecuted.
这是他演讲的核心。这是他信息的核心。政府失控了。它是冲着你们来的。我是那个阻挡在前的人。这就是我被起诉的原因。
Prosecutorial misconduct is their new tool, and they are willing to use it at levels never seen before.
检察官的不当行为是他们的新工具，他们愿意以史无前例的程度来使用它。
The impression that people have is that Trump hasn't changed. Yeah, he's outrageous. Yeah, he does controversial stuff. But that's actually not correct. Trump has changed at least the message. This is a very different campaign. This is not the campaign that got him elected to the White House in 2016. And it's not the campaign that he waged in 2020. This is different.
人们的印象是特朗普没有变。是的，他很离谱。是的，他做有争议的事情。但这实际上是不正确的。特朗普至少改变了信息。这是一场非常不同的竞选。这与让他2016年入主白宫的竞选不同。也不是他2020年进行的竞选。这次很不同。
For those who have been wronged and betrayed, of which there are many people out there that have been wronged and betrayed, I am your retribution. We will take care of it.
对于那些曾经被冤枉和背叛的人，外面有很多人被冤枉和背叛，我就是你们的报应。我们会解决它的。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
We will take care of it.
我们会解决它的。
This is something that Jonathan thinks lots of people might not have noticed until lately, the degree to which Donald Trump's campaign this time around is about getting back at his enemies. Jonathan tries to capture this in his book about Trump, Tired of Winning, which is actually the inspiration for today's show.
这是乔纳森认为很多人直到最近才注意到的一点，即唐纳德·特朗普这次竞选在多大程度上是为了向他的敌人复仇。乔纳森试图在他的特朗普著作《厌倦了胜利》中捕捉到这一点，这也是今天节目的灵感来源。
And what exactly might Donald Trump's revenge look like if he got back into office? Well, in some ways, it's still hard to say. Here's the best information out there on this.
如果唐纳德·特朗普重返办公室，他的复仇究竟会是什么样子？好吧，在某些方面，这仍然很难说。这里有关于此的最好信息。
Number one on his agenda, for a long time, seemed to be that he was going to go after other Republicans, specifically people who had been his allies and turned against him. That's who he seemed to be the most angry about. And we know this because people close to Trump told reporters like Isaac Arnsdorf from The Washington Post that this is who he talked about going after. Isaac heard the retribution speech.
他的议程中，长期以来第一位的似乎是他要追究其他共和党人的责任，特别是那些曾经是他的盟友后来却反对他的人。这正是他似乎最生气的人。我们知道这一点，是因为接近特朗普的人告诉《华盛顿邮报》的艾萨克·阿恩斯多夫等人，这就是他谈论要追究的人。艾萨克听到了那次“报应”演讲。
And I didn't really think about it as a synonym for revenge until we were talking to people who had heard Trump say privately, no, actually, there are specific people who we are going to punish for the crime of criticizing Donald Trump.
直到我们与听过特朗普私下说话的人交谈时，我才真正把这个词当作复仇的同义词来思考，他说，不，实际上，有特定的人我们要因为批评唐纳德·特朗普这一罪行而惩罚他们。
People like his former Attorney General Bill Barr, who called Trump's idea that the election was stolen "total nonsense." Or the former chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff, Mark Milley; they had a falling out. In public, Trump talks about locking up Republicans like Liz Cheney, the top Republican in the January 6 hearings.
比如他的前司法部长比尔·巴尔，他称特朗普关于选举被窃取的想法是“完全胡扯”。或者参谋长联席会议前主席马克·米利；他们闹翻了。公开场合，特朗普谈论关押像利兹·切尼这样的共和党人，她是1月6日听证会中的高级共和党人。
And how could he do this? Well, the second thing that we know about Donald Trump's retribution is that he's probably going to use the Department of Justice to go after his enemies if he takes the White House again, and other parts of government as well. He tells people that's what he wants to do.
他怎么能这样做呢？好吧，关于唐纳德·特朗普的报应，我们知道的第二件事是，如果他再次入主白宫，他很可能会利用司法部去对付他的敌人，以及政府的其他部门。他告诉人们他想这么做。
And also, people from his first administration have come forward, talked about how he wanted to do that during his first term in office, but he was stopped. Trump's former Attorney General Jeff Sessions, is quoted in the Mueller report, saying that Trump asked him to authorize an investigation into Hillary Clinton.
此外，来自他第一届政府的人也站出来谈论他在第一个任期内是如何想这样做，但他被阻止了。特朗普的前司法部长杰夫·塞申斯在穆勒报告中被引用，说特朗普要求他授权调查希拉里·克林顿。
His former Chief of Staff John Kelly told The New York Times about how, during his first term, Trump asked him to sic the IRS on former FBI director James Comey. He told The Washington Post that Trump would often suggest using the Department of Justice or the FBI to prosecute his political enemies. Again, The Washington Post's Isaac Arnsdorf.
他的前幕僚长约翰·凯利告诉《纽约时报》，在第一个任期内，特朗普曾要求他派国税局去对付前联邦调查局局长詹姆斯·科米。他告诉《华盛顿邮报》，特朗普经常建议利用司法部或联邦调查局去起诉他的政治敌人。同样是《华盛顿邮报》的艾萨克·阿恩斯多夫。
Kelly would just kind of say, yes, sir, and then kind of sit on it until he forgot about it and moved on. This is not a secret that Trump wanted to use power this way when he was president the first time. But Jeff Sessions didn't do it. John Kelly didn't do it. And guess what? They are not going to be there in a second term.
凯利只会说，是的，长官，然后把它搁置一边，直到他忘记并继续前进。特朗普在担任总统时想以这种方式行使权力并不是什么秘密。但杰夫·塞申斯没有这样做。约翰·凯利没有这样做。你猜怎么着？他们在第二个任期内不会在那里了。
Trump has told people that his biggest regret from his first term was appointing people who told him no like that. And he's not going to do it again. And the truth is, there's no law to stop any president from using the Department of Justice to go after people this way. It's just tradition. Which brings me to number three, Democrats. I know; this one's not a surprise.
特朗普告诉人们，他第一个任期最大的遗憾就是任命了像那样对他说不的人。他不会再犯同样的错误了。事实是，没有任何法律能阻止任何总统利用司法部去这样对付别人。这只是传统。这让我想到了第三点，民主党人。我知道，这一点并不令人惊讶。
I will appoint a real special prosecutor to go after the most corrupt president in the history of the United States of America, Joe Biden--
我将任命一位真正的特别检察官，去追究美国历史上最腐败的总统，乔·拜登——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
--and the entire Biden crime family and all others involved with the destruction of our elections, our borders, and our country itself. They're destroying our country.
——以及整个拜登犯罪家族，以及所有参与破坏我们的选举、边界和国家本身的人。他们正在摧毁我们的国家。
And here's number four-- he'll target low-level government officials who stopped him in the past.
这是第四点——他将针对过去阻止他的低级别政府官员。
I will totally obliterate the deep state. We will obliterate the deep state. And we know who they are. I know exactly who they are.
我将彻底消灭深层政府。我们将消灭深层政府。我们知道他们是谁。我完全知道他们是谁。
He tried to accomplish that in the last months of his first term by changing the rules with an executive order so that he could fire civil servants who didn't do what he wanted. When Joe Biden took office, Biden reversed that policy to what it was. But it's been reported that Trump loyalists are planning to bring it back.
他在第一个任期的最后几个月里试图通过发布行政命令改变规则来实现这一目标，以便他可以解雇那些不按他意愿行事的公务员。当乔·拜登上台时，拜登将该政策恢复到了原来的样子。但据报道，特朗普的支持者正计划恢复它。
There's one more thing to keep in mind, as we contemplate what retribution might mean in a second Trump term. And that's how Donald Trump and his allies see the powers of the president. Trump's lawyers have been arguing lately in the Supreme Court, in the Georgia vote fraud case, that the president has enormous latitude to use the arms of government to do whatever he wants, much greater latitude than previous presidents have taken.
当我们思考在特朗普第二个任期内“报应”可能意味着什么时，还有一件事要牢记。那就是唐纳德·特朗普及其盟友如何看待总统的权力。特朗普的律师最近在最高法院的佐治亚州选票欺诈案中辩称，总统拥有巨大的自由裁量权去使用政府工具做他想做的任何事，比前几任总统所采取的自由裁量权大得多。
Trump's lawyers told the Supreme Court that if the president ordered the military to kill a political opponent-- in their view, he could not be prosecuted for that as a crime. The only people who could do anything about it is Congress, and the only thing they can do is impeach him.
特朗普的律师告诉最高法院，如果总统下令军队杀死一名政治对手——在他们看来，他不能因此被起诉为犯罪。唯一能对此做点什么的人是国会，而他们唯一能做的就是弹劾他。
Over the past year, Donald Trump has gone through periods where he really was not talking about retaliation that much. Then a week ago, of course, he was found guilty on 34 felony counts in New York City, and retribution is back in force. Only now, he's been joined by an army of furious right-wing commentators and politicians who are demanding prosecutions of Democrats in retaliation for Trump's court cases.
在过去的一年里，唐纳德·特朗普经历了一些他并没有太多谈论报复的时期。然后一周前，当然，他在纽约市被判34项重罪成立，“报应”又卷土重来。只是现在，他加入了一支由愤怒的右翼评论员和政客组成的军队，他们要求起诉民主党人，以作为对特朗普诉讼案件的报复。
If the Democrats are going to play this game, we've got to play the same. We have to play by their rules. Now, when are we going to start arresting Democrats? That's what I want to know.
如果民主党人要玩这个游戏，我们也必须玩。我们必须按照他们的规则行事。现在，我们什么时候开始逮捕民主党人？这就是我想知道的。
Republican AGs all over the country should pursue their own indictments. Take corrupt Democrats. Put them on trial in front of juries that already hate them before the trial even begins.
全国各地的共和党总检察长都应该追求他们自己的起诉书。抓捕腐败的民主党人。在陪审团面前审判他们，这些陪审团在审判开始前就已经恨他们了。
Those were Todd Starnes on the Truth Network and Matt Walsh, who has nearly 3 million subscribers on YouTube. Here's Donald Trump, Jr.
那是“真相网络”上的托德·斯塔恩斯和在YouTube上有近300万订阅者的马特·沃尔什。这是小唐纳德·特朗普。
(SUBJECT) DONALD TRUMP, JR: If we don't start fighting fire with fire, they're just going to keep doing it. And they'll take their wins, and they'll laugh. And when we do it back, they'll say, you're threatening democracy. It's like, wait, you're the ones literally trying to jail your political opposition.
小唐纳德·特朗普：（发言）如果我们不开始以牙还牙，他们只会继续这样做。他们会接受他们的胜利，然后嘲笑。而当我们反击时，他们会说，你在威胁民主。就像，等等，你们才是真正在试图把政治反对派关进监狱的人。
So, what we have this year is an unusual candidate who is promising something we have not seen in a presidential candidate before, that once he gets into office, he's going to take retribution on those who have opposed him. And he's telling us that he believes he has broad powers to command the Justice Department and other branches of government to help him do that.
所以，我们今年有一位不寻常的候选人，他承诺了一些我们在之前的总统候选人身上没有见过的事情，那就是一旦他进入办公室，他将对那些反对他的人进行报应。他告诉我们，他相信他拥有广泛的权力去指挥司法部和政府的其他部门来帮助他做到这一点。
We wanted to take an hour to think about what that might look like and what it might mean for the people who are going to be most affected by it, and that is the people who've crossed him in the past, people on his enemies list. How seriously are they taking this? After all, Donald Trump says a lot of shit that he never really delivers on. He never fully built that wall with Mexico. Mexico did not pay for any of it. He never did lock up Hillary Clinton, though he did try.
我们想花一个小时思考那可能是什么样子，以及这对那些最受影响的人意味着什么，那就是那些过去冒犯过他的人，在他敌人名单上的人。他们对此有多认真？毕竟，唐纳德·特朗普说了许多他从未真正兑现的废话。他从来没有完全建起那堵与墨西哥的墙。墨西哥没有支付其中的任何费用。他也没有把希拉里·克林顿关进监狱，尽管他确实尝试过。
As I speak these words, Trump is leading in three of the six swing states, tied in the other three. Today we visit with a few of the people that Trump hates as they try to puzzle out what Trump might do to them. How do you plan for this? We get a variety of answers. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
在我说这些话的时候，特朗普在六个摇摆州中的三个州处于领先地位，在其他三个州打平。今天，我们采访了一些特朗普讨厌的人，他们试图理清特朗普可能会对他们做什么。你如何为此做计划？我们得到了各种各样的答案。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请留下来。
Act One, Republicans Who Crossed Trump. So we're going to start today with two Republicans who are both pretty worried about what Donald Trump might do to them if he returns to office. One of them was a die-hard Trump loyalist. One of them was a die-hard Trump opponent. Alix Spiegel visited with them.
第一幕，冒犯特朗普的共和党人。所以我们今天从两位共和党人开始，他们都很担心如果唐纳德·特朗普重返办公室，他可能会对他们做什么。其中一个是坚定的特朗普忠诚派。其中一个是坚定的特朗普反对派。阿利克斯·斯皮格尔采访了他们。
Plainville, Kansas, is a small town, less than 2,000 people, the kind of place that feels very far away from the rest of the world, from its noise and its concerns and its dangers, which I think is part of what attracted Stephanie Grisham to the area.
堪萨斯州的普莱恩维尔是一个小镇，人口不到2000人，是一个感觉离世界其他地方非常遥远的地方，远离它的喧嚣、它的担忧和它的危险，我认为这正是吸引斯蒂芬妮·格里森来到这个地区的部分原因。
See this lady right here?
看到这位女士了吗？
A 70-ish year old woman in a colorful hat passes in front of Stephanie's car.
一位戴着彩色帽子的70多岁妇女在斯蒂芬妮的车前经过。
I really want to be her friend. She's always dressed to the nines and goes to all the high school football games. And I just love her.
我真的很想成为她的朋友。她总是打扮得花枝招展，去看所有的高中橄榄球比赛。我只是很喜欢她。
Stephanie moved here from DC four years ago.
斯蒂芬妮四年前从华盛顿特区搬到这里。
Wow, this is a different scene, huh?
哇，这真是一个不同的场景，嗯？
Uh-huh. It's been a lot to get used to, but man, I've sure grown to love it. I really have.
嗯。有很多需要习惯的地方，但天哪，我确实已经开始爱上它了。我真的爱上了。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Stephanie's previous scene was the White House. She was one of the Trump staffers who lasted the longest. She went to a Trump rally two weeks after his descent on the golden escalator and was amazed by how he connected with the crowd. She'd never seen anything like it. So she signed up and lasted all the way until the storming of the Capitol on January 6.
斯蒂芬妮之前的场景是白宫。她是任职时间最长的特朗普工作人员之一。他在金色自动扶梯上缓缓而下两周后，她参加了特朗普的集会，并对他与人群的联系方式感到惊讶。她从未见过这样的事情。所以她报名参加了，一直坚持到1月6日国会大厦遭到冲击。
I was interested in talking with Stephanie because when she was with the Trumps, it was actually part of her job to help them take retribution against their enemies.
我对与斯蒂芬妮交谈很感兴趣，因为当她和特朗普一家在一起时，实际上她工作的一部分就是帮助他们对付他们的敌人。
Stephanie played a variety of roles for the Trumps. She was Melania's Chief of Staff for a time, but she also worked at the highest levels of the West Wing. In fact, at one point she was Press Secretary and Director of Communications for the White House and was also responsible for communications for Melania. PS, she was the only White House Press Secretary to never hold a single press briefing.
斯蒂芬妮为特朗普一家扮演了多种角色。她曾有一段时间担任梅拉尼娅的幕僚长，但她也在西翼的最高层工作。事实上，有一次她是白宫新闻秘书和通讯主任，也负责梅拉尼娅的通讯工作。顺便说一句，她是唯一从未举行过哪怕一次新闻发布会的白宫新闻秘书。
But Stephanie says even outside of her formal White House jobs, she spent a huge amount of time with the Trumps.
但斯蒂芬妮说，即使在她正式的白宫工作之外，她也花大量时间与特朗普一家在一起。
I would always go with them during all the holidays. So I was at Mar-a-Lago with them for Christmas, New Year's, all the way to Easter. So I was just always there.
我总是在所有的假期陪他们。所以我圣诞节、新年一直到复活节都和他们在一起，住在海湖庄园。所以我总是待在那里。
Always there-- so literally in the room at so many critical moments. Like on election night in 2020, it was Stephanie who tiptoed into the First Lady's bedroom around 1:00 to wake her, so Melania would be dressed and ready to go on camera when Trump came out to speak.
总是待在那里——所以确实在许多关键时刻就在房间里。比如2020年选举之夜，大约凌晨1点，是斯蒂芬妮蹑手蹑脚走进第一夫人的卧室叫醒她，这样当特朗普出来讲话时，梅拉尼娅就能打扮好并准备好上镜。
As Melania got ready in the bathroom, Stephanie says that she sat with Barron at the end of her bed, watching television news and calling out the results so Melania would know which states had been decided. Really, Stephanie's been through all kinds of things with the Trumps.
当梅拉尼娅在浴室里准备时，斯蒂芬妮说她坐在床脚陪巴伦，看着电视新闻并喊出结果，这样梅拉尼娅就会知道哪些州已经决定了。真的，斯蒂芬妮和特朗普一家经历过各种各样的事情。
I mean, there was the time he felt that he needed to tell me that Stormy Daniels was wrong about his penis size. So that was a really weird conversation. And he called me from Air Force One, which made the whole conversation worse because there's a tiny delay between the person on the plane and the person on the ground.
我的意思是，有一次他觉得他需要告诉我斯托米·丹尼尔斯关于他阴茎大小的说法是错误的。所以那是一次非常奇怪的谈话。而且他是从“空军一号”上打给我的，这让整个谈话更糟糕了，因为飞机上的人和地面上的人之间有轻微的延迟。
January 6 was the turning point for Stephanie. She says she was horrified that Trump didn't immediately denounce the breach of the Capitol and attacks on Mike Pence. And when she reached out to Melania to ask her to intervene with her husband, Melania said no. For Stephanie, that was the last straw. She told me she sent her resignation email about 15 minutes later.
1月6日是斯蒂芬妮的转折点。她说她对特朗普没有立即谴责国会大厦的缺口和对迈克·彭斯的攻击感到震惊。当她联系梅拉尼娅请求她干预她的丈夫时，梅拉尼娅拒绝了。对斯蒂芬妮来说，那是最后一根稻草。她告诉我，大约15分钟后她就发送了辞职邮件。
But Stephanie didn't stop at resigning. She also agreed to testify for the January 6 Committee, spoke out against Donald Trump on television, and wrote a tell-all book about her experience with the Trumps that became a national bestseller. From a Trump perspective, Stephanie says she's sinned in almost every possible way she could sin. And she's been clear from the beginning, literally from the moment she pressed send on her resignation email, about what that would mean for her.
但斯蒂芬妮并没有止步于辞职。她还同意为1月6日委员会作证，在电视上公开反对唐纳德·特朗普，并写了一本关于她与特朗普一家经历的畅销书，成为了全国畅销书。从特朗普的角度来看，斯蒂芬妮说她几乎在所有可能犯罪的方式上都犯罪了。从她点击辞职邮件发送键的那一刻起，她就从一开始就很清楚这意味着什么。
Oh, I knew I would be cast out. I knew I would immediately be a traitor. I mean, I helped do it to people. If anybody spoke out against Mrs. Trump or the President, I was the one issuing terrible statements, calling them a liar, saying they were looking for fame.
哦，我知道我会被抛弃。我知道我立刻会成为一名叛徒。我的意思是，我帮助别人这样做过。如果有人反对特朗普夫人或总统，我就是那个发表可怕声明的人，称他们是骗子，说他们是在寻求名声。
Stephanie says that since she was a Trump true believer, she mostly felt fine about this. She saw it as an important part of her job to push back. But still, she says, there were some uncomfortable moments.
斯蒂芬妮说，因为她曾是特朗普的真正信徒，她大多对此感觉良好。她认为这是她工作中反击的重要组成部分。但即便如此，她说，还是有一些不舒服的时刻。
I called Mitt Romney a "scum," I think. And this is a man I had worked for and actually had really respected and was always really kind when I ever passed by him. And I remember right when the word "scum" came out of my mouth, I, inside, was like, oh, that was way too far, way too far. That was really harsh, and that was pretty gross of me.
我想我称米特·罗姆尼为“人渣”。这是我曾经为之工作过的人，实际上真的很尊重他，而且每次我经过他身边时，他总是真的很友善。我记得当“人渣”这个词从我嘴里出来时，我在心里想，哦，那太过分了，太过分了。这真的很刻薄，我自己这样做很恶心。
And of course, I get back to the White House, and I got just praise from the President. That was great. You were so tough. You're so tough, you know. So then that makes you feel good because now the President is happy with you.
当然，我回到白宫，我得到了总统的赞扬。那太棒了。你太强硬了。你太强硬了，你知道。所以这让你感觉很好，因为现在总统对你很高兴。
And that's one of the things about Donald Trump. He doesn't give you a specific direction. He just says, go after him. And he leaves you to do the dirty work.
这就是唐纳德·特朗普的一点。他不会给你具体的指导。他只是说，去对付他。然后他就让你去做肮脏的工作。
Stephanie says one of the only times Trump gave her very specific directions was after John Kelly stepped down as Chief of Staff and then criticized Trump in the press. Stephanie says at one point Trump called her to say she needed to make a public statement savaging Kelly, who was a person Stephanie liked and respected.
斯蒂芬妮说，特朗普给她非常具体指示的唯一一次是在约翰·凯利辞去幕僚长职务并在媒体上批评特朗普之后。斯蒂芬妮说，有一次特朗普打电话给她，说她需要发表公开声明猛烈抨击凯利，凯利是一个斯蒂芬妮喜欢并尊重的人。
He said that I needed to call this reporter and say, General Kelly doesn't understand "the genius of our great President." And he said, take it down, take this down. So I remember I wrote it down, and I hung up the phone and I sat there. And I remember, I called my boyfriend. I called one of the deputy chiefs of staff at the time. And I think I called just, like, my best friend.
他说我需要打电话给那个记者，说：凯利将军不了解“我们伟大总统的天才”。他说，记下来，把这个记下来。所以我记得我把它写下来，挂断了电话，我就坐在那里。我记得，我打电话给我的男朋友。我当时打电话给副幕僚长之一。我想我只是打了电话给我的好朋友。
And I knew. I was like, oh, my gosh, he wants me to say this. This is horrible, right? And everyone was like, yeah, that's really horrible. But I picked up the phone, and I did it. And it sounded like I worked for Kim Jong-un. Like, "the genius of our great President"-- who says that? But I did.
我知道。我在想，天哪，他要我说这个。这太可怕了，对吧？每个人都说，是的，那真的很可怕。但我拿起电话，照做了。听起来就像我为金正恩工作一样。就像，“我们伟大总统的天才”——谁会这么说？但我做了。
And so he called me later that day, the President, and said, hey, that was great. I really appreciate what you said. That was really tough. And I'm thinking, you had me write that down.
所以他那天晚些时候打电话给我，总统，说，嘿，那太棒了。我真的很感谢你所说的。那真的很强硬。我在想，你让我写下这些。
It was just very, very clear, Stephanie says, that Trump wanted you to be as ruthless as possible with his enemies. She says Trump seemed to genuinely admire people who were ruthless.
斯蒂芬妮说，很清楚，特朗普希望你尽可能冷酷地对待他的敌人。她说特朗普似乎真心钦佩那些冷酷无情的人。
I remember one specific time when we were in a bilat with President Erdogan of Turkey. And we were all sitting around this table. I was, I think, maybe the only woman in the room, maybe a couple others.
我记得有一次我们在与土耳其总统埃尔多安会谈。我们都坐在那张桌子旁。我想，我可能是房间里唯一的女性，可能还有其他几个。
But out of the blue, literally, he just yells down to me, Stephanie, who do you think is the biggest killer, this guy or President Xi of China? He asked me that in a room of 30 to 40 people. I'm supposed to decide who's the biggest murderer, as if that's cool.
但出乎意料的是，他直接对我大喊，斯蒂芬妮，你认为谁是最大的杀人犯，这家伙还是中国的习主席？他在一个有30到40人的房间里这样问我。我必须决定谁是最大的杀人犯，好像那很酷一样。
And I remember, I just said, I don't know. This guy looks pretty tough, sir. [LAUGHS AWKWARDLY] You know, you laugh about it.
我记得，我只是说，我不知道。这家伙看起来很强硬，长官。[尴尬地笑] 你知道，你会对此发笑。
And I remember afterwards, he came up to me and grabbed my elbow. And he goes, hey, just so you know, it's President Xi. I've seen him do some shit. And that was the moment that I was like, he really loves this. He really loves-- he wanted to know who has murdered more of their own people, their own people. Ah!
我还记得事后，他走近我，抓住了我的手肘。他说，嘿，你要知道，是习主席。我见过他做一些事。那一刻我心想，他真的很喜欢这个。他真的很喜欢——他想知道谁杀死了更多的自己人，他们自己的人。啊！
Unfortunately for Stephanie, Donald Trump doesn't usually forget his grudges. And maybe worse, it's not just Donald who's angry with her.
不幸的是，对于斯蒂芬妮来说，唐纳德·特朗普通常不会忘记他的怨恨。更糟糕的是，不仅唐纳德对她生气。
The worst part for me is that I'm on her radar. So like, a General Kelly is not on Melania Trump's radar. So I've got both of them. [LAUGHS] And I know that she is very, very good at revenge as well.
对我来说最糟糕的部分是，我在她的雷达上。所以，凯利将军并不在梅拉尼娅·特朗普的雷达上。所以两人都在针对我。[笑] 而且我知道她也同样非常擅长报复。
Now, I want to be clear. Stephanie seems to genuinely care for and, in some ways, even admire Melania Trump. Since she was Melania's Chief of Staff and Communications Director, they got to know each other pretty well. And you can tell when you read Stephanie's book that even now, she has fond feelings for her former boss, misses her even. But she's seen what Melania's capable of. She says Melania has tried to use the government to go after enemies in the past.
现在，我想澄清一下。斯蒂芬妮似乎真心关心梅拉尼娅·特朗普，在某些方面甚至崇拜她。由于她是梅拉尼娅的幕僚长和通讯总监，他们彼此相当了解。当你读斯蒂芬妮的书时，你可以看出，即使现在，她对前老板仍有深厚的感情，甚至很想念她。但她见识过梅拉尼娅的能力。她说梅拉尼娅过去曾试图利用政府去对付敌人。
She had a friend who kind of worked for her, Stephanie Winston Wolkoff, who also wrote a book about her while we were in the White House. And when Stephanie's book came out, Melania wanted to sue her. Because that's what they do. The Trumps sue people.
她有一个朋友，斯蒂芬妮·温斯顿·沃尔科夫，她也曾为她工作过，当我们还在白宫时，她写了一本关于她的书。当斯蒂芬妮的书出来时，梅拉尼娅想要起诉她。因为这就是他们做的。特朗普一家起诉别人。
And Melania's reasoning was she wanted to sue Stephanie for violating a non-disclosure agreement that Stephanie had signed-- well, we all signed. But those had been deemed that they didn't really matter because we work for the government.
梅拉尼娅的理由是她想因为斯蒂芬妮违反了保密协议而起诉她——嗯，我们都签了。但那些协议被认为并不重要，因为我们为政府工作。
And Pat Cipollone, our attorney, our White House attorney, kept telling Melania, no, if you want to do this, you need to do it with your personal lawyer. This isn't a government thing. And Melania was like, nope. Nope, I want to sue her. I want to sue her.
我们的律师帕特·西波隆，我们的白宫律师，一直在告诉梅拉尼娅，不，如果你想这样做，你需要用你的私人律师来做。这不是政府的事。梅拉尼娅说，不。不，我想起诉她。我想起诉她。
And she forced Pat Cipollone to make the Justice Department take it on. Pat said, two or three times, this should be your personal lawyer. This is not a government situation. And she finally, one day, said, I don't care. Do it. And so they did it.
她强迫帕特·西波隆让司法部接手。帕特两三次说，这应该是你的私人律师。这不是政府情况。有一天她终于说，我不在乎。去做吧。所以他们就做了。
I reached out to Pat Cipollone and the Justice Department to confirm Stephanie's story. Neither would comment. The Justice Department did file a suit against Stephanie Winston Wolkoff shortly after her book came out. The Biden administration dropped that suit its first month in office.
我联系了帕特·西波隆和司法部以证实斯蒂芬妮的故事。双方都没有评论。司法部确实在斯蒂芬妮·温斯顿·沃尔科夫的书出版后不久对她提起了诉讼。拜登政府在其执政的第一个月就撤销了该诉讼。
But this story points to something that really worries Stephanie about a second Trump term. She believes there will be many fewer Pat Cipollines-- people willing to push back or say no to the Trumps-- because, like Ira mentioned earlier, Trump has told people he's not going to appoint anyone this time around who will tell him no.
但这个故事指出了斯蒂芬妮对第二个特朗普任期真正担心的事情。她认为帕特·西波隆那样的人会少得多——愿意反击或对特朗普一家说不的人——因为，就像艾拉之前提到的，特朗普告诉人们他这次不会任命任何会对他哪怕说不的人。
And there's something else that Stephanie is worried about in a second Trump term, something I heard from a few people. It's not how he'd use government institutions for personal retribution. It's another weapon at his disposal.
而且斯蒂芬妮对第二个特朗普任期还有其他担心的事情，这是我从几个人那里听到的。这不是他如何利用政府机构进行个人报复，而是他掌握的另一种武器。
He and she, they both, can call forth these armies of people-- mostly online, but certainly, we've seen, with January 6 and other situations, that some are in public. And you just get besieged with hate and bullying. And they know that, and they wield that power like no problem.
他和她，他们俩，都可以召唤这些人群——主要是网上的，但当然，我们已经看到，在1月6日和其他情况下，有些在公开场合。你就会被仇恨和欺凌所包围。他们知道这一点，他们毫无问题地行使那种权力。
And I remember, there were times with Mrs. Trump that I'd say, do you want me to put a statement out about this person who said something bad about you? And she'd say, no, no, no. We will let all my fans get them. And that meant the people online, all her supporters who would go after this person. And they do.
我记得，有几次特朗普夫人说，你想要我发一份关于这个说你坏话的人的声明吗？她说，不，不，不。我们会让我所有的粉丝去对付他们。这意味着网上的人，所有会去攻击这个人的支持者。他们确实会这么做。
Several people I spoke to for this story told me that they feared Trump would encourage a kind of culture of vengefulness in his second term, and that MAGA zealots might feel liberated to do what they want because Trump's government will have their backs. After all, he has already promised to pardon the January 6 rioters, which brings me to Fred Wellman and the way that fear of retribution from Trump supporters can infect a life.
几个我为这个故事采访过的人告诉我，他们担心特朗普会在他的第二个任期内鼓励一种复仇文化，MAGA狂热者可能会感到自由，因为特朗普的政府会支持他们。毕竟，他已经承诺赦免1月6日的暴徒，这让我想到了弗雷德·韦尔曼以及担心特朗普支持者报复如何感染生活的方式。
Fred lives in a suburb of St. Louis on this residential street with modest houses. And he told me that a couple of months ago, right before bed, he let his dog River out for her bedtime stretch.
弗雷德住在圣路易斯郊区这条有着简朴房子的住宅街上。他告诉我，几个月前，就在睡觉前，他让他的狗里弗出去做睡前伸展。
I open the door. She jumps down three steps. And sitting right here with those garbage cans are was a pickup truck, sitting there idling, facing my house. And I'm like, OK. I watched them for a second. I couldn't see-- tinted windows. Couldn't see what was going on. I'm like, that's strange.
我打开门。她跳下三级台阶。就在这些垃圾桶旁边停着一辆皮卡车，就在那里怠速，面对着我的房子。我在想，好的。我看了他们一眼。我看不见——深色车窗。看不见发生了什么。我在想，真奇怪。
You're talking 10 o'clock at night. What got me going was I gave him bug eyes. I looked at him. I gave the stink eye. It was like, what are you doing here? Just looked. And he had to know I saw him. And I came back in. They didn't leave, which is really suspicious.
那是晚上10点。让我开始行动的是我给了他们一对虫眼。我盯着他。我给了他一个厌恶的眼神。就像，你在这里干什么？只是看。他肯定知道我看见他了。我进来了。他们没有离开，这非常可疑。
And in your mind, what was the first thought you had about who could be sitting in that truck?
在你的脑海里，关于谁可能坐在那辆车里的第一个想法是什么？
Trump supporters. MAGA, MAGA extremists, if you will. I'm on the list. I'm on the list.
特朗普的支持者。MAGA，MAGA极端分子，如果你愿意这么说。我在名单上。我在名单上。
And what do you mean by list?
你的名单是什么意思？
Of enemies. I'm on the MAGA enemies list.
敌人的名单。我在MAGA敌人名单上。
To be clear, it's not a literal list, but Fred's definitely done enough to get on the wrong side of Trump world. Fred was executive director of the Lincoln Project. Maybe you've heard of it-- it's this group of high-profile Republican operatives who set out to use their political know-how to keep Trump out of power in 2020 and immediately attracted attention and money.
说清楚，这不是一个字面上的名单，但弗雷德确实做了足够多的事情来站在特朗普世界的对立面。弗雷德是“林肯计划”的执行主任。也许你听说过——这是一群高调的共和党操盘手，他们决定利用他们的政治知识让特朗普在2020年失去权力，并立即吸引了注意力和金钱。
The group trolled Trump on Twitter daily and spent close to $80 million on a series of viral anti-Trump campaign ads. Trump responded with rage tweets; there were a bunch. And those written attacks from Trump almost immediately translated into actual attacks from Trump supporters.
该组织每天在推特上嘲弄特朗普，并在系列病毒式反特朗普竞选广告上花费了近8000万美元。特朗普用愤怒的推文回应；有好多条。而特朗普那些书面攻击几乎立即转化为了特朗普支持者的实际攻击。
One Lincoln Project founder I talked to said that hundreds of boxes of excrement were mailed to his house. Then, a couple of months ago, Fred discovered that all of his information and the information of his family members had been posted on this doxing site that he didn't want to name but which he showed me during our visit.
一位我采访过的“林肯计划”创始人说，数以百计的粪便盒被寄到了他家。然后，几个月前，弗雷德发现他所有的信息以及他家庭成员的信息都被发布在这个他不想点名但他在我们访问期间展示给我的“人肉搜索”网站上。
I keep it open.
我把它打开。
I love the picture of the--
我喜欢那张——
Yeah, it's great.
是的，很棒。
--the devil. It's very subtle.
——恶魔的照片。非常微妙。
There it is, Fred Wellman. That's my stepson. That's my dad who's dead. That's my ex-wife's ex-husband. That's my brother. That's my mother. They do have all the emails and socials right.
在那儿，弗雷德·韦尔曼。那是我的继子。那是死去的我爸爸。那是我前妻的前丈夫。那是我的兄弟。那是我的母亲。他们的电子邮件和社交账号完全正确。
They have all your email? They have all your--
他们有你所有的电子邮件？他们有你所有的——
Yeah, but that's not me. I guess there's a Fred Wellman who's a realtor they keep mistaking for me.
是的，但那不是我。我想有一个弗雷德·韦尔曼是一个房地产经纪人，他们一直把我误认为是他。
Poor Fred Wellman.
可怜的弗雷德·韦尔曼。
I know.
我知道。
Have you reached out to him and--
你有联系他并——
Oh, no.
哦，不。
--be like, sorry, guy?
——就像，抱歉，伙计？
He should change his name. I was first.
他应该改名。我是先来的。
At the top of the page was a box which listed how many people had searched for Fred's name. There were 187. And now this truck was sitting near his driveway. Could it be a Trump supporter?
页面顶部有一个框，列出了有多少人搜索过弗雷德的名字。有187个。现在这辆卡车停在他的车道附近。可能是特朗普的支持者吗？
So anyway, I did what I do, which is-- [LAUGHS] you know.
所以不管怎样，我做了我该做的事，就是——[笑] 你知道。
Just explain what this is.
只是解释一下这是什么。
I have a 9 millimeter handgun, a Smith and Wesson 9 millimeter.
我有一把9毫米手枪，一把史密斯威森9毫米手枪。
In the drawer by your bed?
在床边的抽屉里？
Yeah. Yeah, or actually, on the nightstand.
是的。是的，或者实际上，在床头柜上。
Before getting sideways with Trump world, Fred didn't keep guns in his house, much less on his bedside table. It's not that Fred's uncomfortable with guns. Fred's military. He went to West Point, was a protégé of David Petraeus, served in Desert Storm, and had three combat tours in Iraq.
在与特朗普世界闹翻之前，弗雷德家里不放枪，更不用说放在床头柜上了。并不是弗雷德对枪感到不舒服。弗雷德是军人。他去了西点军校，是大卫·彼得雷乌斯的门生，在沙漠风暴中服役，并在伊拉克执行过三次战斗任务。
It's just that after his time in the military, Fred struggled very seriously with PTSD. And so to be safe, about seven years ago, he got rid of all of his weapons. He told me it was the responsible thing to do for his kids, for his family.
只是在服完兵役后，弗雷德患上了非常严重的创伤后应激障碍。所以为了安全起见，大约七年前，他处理掉了所有的武器。他告诉我，这对他的孩子，对他的家庭来说是负责任的做法。
Easy access to guns kills veterans. So it was a big deal for me to go ahead and get one.
轻易接触枪支会害死老兵。所以买一把枪对我来说是一件大事。
Did you have-- is it OK for me to ask? Did you at a certain point have real trouble with suicidal ideation?
你有——我可以问吗？你在某个时候有真正的自杀意念问题吗？
[LAUGHS] Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. That was a constant companion to me for many years. Many, many years. But I went into treatment for PTSD back in 2018, as my wife and I separated. And I took that, and I'm still in therapy, still treating it. I've come a long way.
[笑] 哦，是的。哦，是的。那是多年来一直陪伴我的东西。很多，很多年。但我是在2018年，我和妻子分居时接受了创伤后应激障碍的治疗。我接受了那个，我现在还在接受治疗，还在治疗它。我走了很长一段路。
That's why Fred swore off guns, at least until he was promoted to executive director of the Lincoln Project in 2021. MAGA supporters already hated them, but on his first day on the job, something happened that unleashed a whole new level of fury at the group. One of the Lincoln Project's founders admitted to sending sexually suggestive messages to young men, which turned MAGA's anger at the group up to 11.
这就是弗雷德放弃枪支的原因，至少在他2021年被提升为“林肯计划”执行主任之前。MAGA支持者已经恨他们了，但在他上任的第一天，发生了一件事，引发了对该组织全新的愤怒水平。“林肯计划”的一位创始人承认向年轻人发送带有性暗示的信息，这让MAGA对该组织的愤怒升级到了11级。
The daily barrage was so extreme the professional security consultants hired to do a threat analysis told Fred and his colleagues to avoid going outside. Fred felt he had no choice. He says he drove to a store and purchased the Smith and Wesson, carried it everywhere, even inside his house.
日常的攻击是如此极端，聘请来进行威胁分析的专业安全顾问告诉弗雷德和他的同事们避免外出。弗雷德感到他别无选择。他说他开车去商店买了那把史密斯威森手枪，随身携带，甚至在家里也是如此。
I need to have it in the same room just to make sure, in case somebody kicked the door in or came in the back door, that I'd at least be able to fight back. I had a whole plan where I'd fall back. I set up a safe room. I mean, just put my extra ammo in the bathroom upstairs, so if I had to retreat to the bathroom I'd have the extra ammo in the bathroom. I mean, it was pretty intense for a while there.
我需要把它放在同一个房间里，只是为了确保，万一有人踹门进来或者从后门进来，我至少能够反击。我有一个完整的计划，我会在哪里撤退。我建立了一个安全室。我的意思是，只是把额外的弹药放在楼上的浴室里，所以如果我不得不撤退到浴室，我就有额外的弹药。我的意思是，那段时间非常紧张。
Again, I'm an old soldier. I'm not going to sit back and let them kill me. Being aware of my surroundings, being aware of my operational security is my way of life now. It has to be. You don't have any choice.
再一次，我是一个老兵。我不会坐以待毙，让他们杀我。意识到我的周围环境，意识到我的操作安全是我现在的生活方式。必须这样。你别无选择。
Which brings me back to that night in late January and the truck parked in front of Fred's driveway. Fred told me he peeked through the blinds with the gun in his hand waiting, until eventually it drove away.
这让我回到了那一月下旬的夜晚和停在弗雷德车道前面的卡车。弗雷德告诉我，他拿着枪透过百叶窗偷偷看，等着，直到它最终开走了。
At the time, did you question, am I being paranoid?
当时，你有怀疑过，我是不是在多疑？
Oh, yeah. I always do. You always do. I mean, why wouldn't you? It's a weird thing to think somebody might want to-- just, it's so ridiculous, the idea. Even somebody who lives this life is wondering, am I just being ridiculous? And I always question that.
哦，是的。我总是这样。你总是这样。我的意思是，你为什么不呢？想到有人可能想——只是，这是如此荒谬，这个想法。即使是过这种生活的人也在怀疑，我是不是只是在变得荒谬？我总是质疑这一点。
Does it bother you to think that you're paranoid?
想到你多疑会困扰你吗？
Mm-hmm, yeah, it does. But that's their goal, right? I mean, the goal, I think, for all these guys, is to make us on edge, to wear us out, to make you quit, to say, you know what? This is too much heat. This is too much danger for me.
嗯，是的，确实。但那是他们的目标，对吧？我的意思是，我认为对所有这些家伙来说，目标是让我们感到紧张，让我们疲惫不堪，让你退出，让你说，你知道吗？这太热了。这对我有太大的危险。
And I have peers who have done that. I have peers who have backed out of their-- quieted down or gone to other things. The goal is-- and I think about it. Why would I not think about it? So they want us to be scared. They want us to chicken out. They want us to be broke. It's like, you see how I live. I live humbly. Go for it, dude. There's nothing more dangerous than a man with zero assets and zero fucks.
我有同行这样做过。我有同行已经退出了他们的——安静下来或转向其他事情。目标是——我一直在考虑它。我为什么不考虑它？所以他们希望我们害怕。他们希望我们当缩头乌龟。他们希望我们破产。就像，你看到我是怎么生活的。我谦卑地生活。尽管来吧，伙计。没有什么比一个零资产、零操心的男人更危险的了。
Yeah, and that's you?
是的，那就是你？
That's me. Oh, yeah, that's me in a million ways. Kids are grown. I'm not married, so my wife's not going to get hit with anything. I'm on my own.
那就是我。哦，是的，那就是我，以一百万种方式。孩子们都长大了。我没有结婚，所以我的妻子不会受到任何牵连。我自己一个人。
Fred and Stephanie both worry that in a second Trump term, he'll install people in the federal government who will come after them-- in the IRS, in the Justice Department. Like, for example, they both think their taxes could be audited.
弗雷德和斯蒂芬妮都担心在第二个特朗普任期内，他会在联邦政府中安插会来对付他们的人——在国税局，在司法部。例如，他们都认为他们的税收可能会被审计。
Or I don't know if they would have DOJ come after me for treason. He was big on treason.
或者我不知道他们是否会用叛国罪来对付我。他很看重叛国。
What do you mean, he was big on treason?
你什么意思，他很看重叛国？
He would always just, if people spoke out against him-- that's treason, that's treason. That's what he felt. It's not going to be just about Donald Trump or Melania Trump. Some people who will also be placed, without a doubt, into the administration, they, too, will be empowered to go after people they perceive were traitors. And so it's going to be a small, little army of people that I think will be just settling all kinds of scores, using the government.
他总是，如果人们反对他——那是叛国，那是叛国。这就是他的感觉。这不仅仅是关于唐纳德·特朗普或梅拉尼娅·特朗普。有些人也将无疑被安插进政府，他们也将被授权去对付他们认为背叛的人。所以我觉得会有一小支军队，他们会解决各种分数，利用政府。
You want to talk about what is it going to look like for people like me. Let's say you say you replace half the IRS with MAGA extremists. And they go through people like me's books. You know as well as I do, I probably didn't cross a T or dot an I. It's not hard to find a crime when you look for it. So what happens with people like me? You see where this goes? It's very easy to use the administrative state, the deep state, if you will, in very evil ways.
你想谈谈这对像我这样的人会是什么样子。假设你说你用MAGA极端分子取代了一半的国税局。他们去查像我这样的人的账本。你像我一样清楚，我可能没有交叉一个T或点一个I。当你寻找它时，找到一个罪行并不难。所以像我这样的人会发生什么？你看到这是要去哪里了吗？利用行政国家，如果可以的话，利用深层政府，以非常邪恶的方式是非常容易的。
Which is why Fred and his girlfriend have been making plans.
这就是为什么弗雷德和他的女朋友一直在制定计划。
Can you just explain the trip that you're going to be taking this summer?
你能解释一下你今年夏天要进行的旅行吗？
Yeah, we're going to go abroad. I've done the research of what needs to do to establish the first steps in the process to find yourself living somewhere else. And we're planning on taking some of those steps this summer, just to be safe, establishing bank accounts and travel patterns, making contact with the local passport offices, those sorts of things.
是的，我们要去国外。我已经研究了建立在其他地方生活的过程的第一步需要做什么。我们计划今年夏天采取其中一些步骤，只是为了安全起见，建立银行账户和旅行模式，与当地护照办公室接触，诸如此类的事情。
There are other ways that Fred has adjusted his life in anticipation of a Trump presidency.
弗雷德在期待特朗普总统任期时，还有其他调整生活的方式。
Explain that. Why? Why are you not married?
解释一下。为什么？为什么你不结婚？
Well, there's no legal entanglement that way. They can't go after her because she's my partner or my wife. There is no-- we have not intertwined our finances, for example, just in case. I do not want my challenges to affect those I love, be it my kids, my partner, even my ex, OK? I do not want them entangled in this.
嗯，那样没有法律纠缠。他们不能因为她是我的伴侣或妻子而针对她。没有——例如，我们没有交织我们的财务，以防万一。我不希望我的挑战影响我爱的人，无论是我的孩子，我的伴侣，甚至是我的前任，好吗？我不希望他们卷入其中。
As for Stephanie, she doesn't like to talk about what she'll do if Trump gets elected for a second term. The only thing she'd say on the record is that she has also considered leaving the country.
至于斯蒂芬妮，她不喜欢谈论如果特朗普赢得第二个任期她会怎么做。她在公开记录中唯一会说的是，她也考虑过离开这个国家。
In fact, Stephanie told me she's in this text group with four women, former Trump administration staffers who have publicly repudiated him. All of them testified in front of the January 6 Committee. She says that when Trump's poll numbers look especially good, they comfort each other with these half-funny, half-serious texts.
事实上，斯蒂芬妮告诉我，她在这个包含四个女人的群聊组中，她们都是曾经公开抛弃他的特朗普政府工作人员。她们都曾在1月6日委员会面前作证。她说，当特朗普的民调数字看起来特别好时，她们用这些半开玩笑、半认真的短信互相安慰。
Our big joke is that we're going to end up in Gitmo. And I'm always telling people, will you just fill my commissary up? I love ramen. I'll just eat ramen all the time.
我们的大笑话是我们将最终进入关塔那摩。我总是告诉人们，你能不能填满我的补给站？我喜欢拉面。我会一直吃拉面。
Do you think that you could end up in jail?
你认为你最终可能会进监狱吗？
Oh, yeah. I don't know for what, but yeah. I mean, I even worry some days about just disappearing one day. Like a black ops. One day Stephanie's just gone. Where'd she go? That's really dramatic. I doubt that would happen, but it has crossed my mind.
哦，是的。我不知道为了什么，但是是的。我的意思是，我甚至担心有一天会突然消失。就像黑色行动。有一天斯蒂芬妮就消失了。她去哪了？这真的很戏剧化。我怀疑会发生这种情况，但这确实出现在我的脑海中。
Because you think they're capable of that?
因为你认为他们有这种能力？
Yeah. I mean, yes.
是的。我的意思是，是的。
Stephanie and Fred know that these hypotheticals seem really extreme, but they feel like they have no choice but to think about them.
斯蒂芬妮和弗雷德知道这些假设看起来真的很极端，但他们觉得除了考虑它们之外别无选择。
It's messed up that the United States of America in 2024, because you have a political difference with someone who ran for office, you actually have to come up with a plan to possibly leave our country.
2024年的美利坚合众国，因为你与一个参加竞选的人有政治分歧，你实际上不得不制定一个可能离开我们国家的计划，这太乱了。
If Donald Trump wins on November 5, Fred and Stephanie will have roughly two months before the new administration takes power to figure out what to do, two months to make a decision about whether to stay or whether to go. In the meantime, they wait. Fred told me that a couple of weeks ago he had another visit from an idling truck.
如果唐纳德·特朗普在11月5日获胜，弗雷德和斯蒂芬妮将在新政府上台前有大约两个月的时间来决定该做什么，两个月的时间来决定是留下来还是离开。与此同时，他们等待着。弗雷德告诉我，几周前他又迎来了一次怠速卡车的访问。
Alix Spiegel is one of the producers of our show.
阿利克斯·斯皮格尔是我们节目的制作人之一。
Coming up, how's the plan for retribution affecting your marriage? And do Trump voters actually give a damn about Trump's calls for retribution? That's in a minute, Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，报复计划是如何影响你的婚姻的？特朗普选民真的在乎特朗普的报复呼吁吗？这一分钟后，芝加哥公共广播，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Come Retribution. One of the current presidential candidates is openly promising revenge if he takes office. We're looking at what that might mean and talking to some of the people he might take revenge upon.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“报应来临”。其中一位目前的总统候选人公开承诺如果他入主办公室就会进行复仇。我们正在审视那可能意味着什么，并与一些他可能报复的人交谈。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The Deep Stater. So like Fred and Stephanie, this next guy is not trying to pick a fight with Donald Trump. He's just trying to do his job.
我们已经到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“深层政府成员”。所以像弗雷德和斯蒂芬妮一样，接下来的这个家伙并不试图与唐纳德·特朗普挑起争端。他只是试图做好他的工作。
Mr. Chairman, ranking members, thank you for the opportunity to address the House Permanent Select Committee on Intelligence.
主席先生，排名委员，谢谢你们让我有机会向众议院常设特别情报委员会致辞。
This is former Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Vindman. He's the White House staffer who went to his superiors and officially reported the phone call that President Donald Trump had that led to his first impeachment trial.
这是前中校亚历山大·温德曼。他是那位向他的上级汇报了唐纳德·特朗普总统那次导致他第一次弹劾审判的电话的白宫工作人员。
You remember this call? It was with the president of Ukraine, Volodymyr Zelenskyy, back in July 2019. Lieutenant Colonel Vindman wrote the talking points for President Trump that day. Trump was supposed to congratulate Zelenskyy for winning a big election-- normal stuff. But instead, Trump famously went off message and asked Zelenskyy for a favor. He asked Zelenskyy to investigate Hunter Biden. Vindman and some other officials were listening in.
你还记得这个电话吗？那是2019年7月与乌克兰总统弗拉基米尔·泽连斯基的通话。温德曼中校那天为特朗普总统写了谈话要点。特朗普本应祝贺泽连斯基赢得了一场大选——正常的事情。但相反，特朗普如人们所知地偏离了主题，并向泽连斯基寻求帮助。他要求泽连斯基调查亨特·拜登。温德曼和其他一些官员正在监听。
I was concerned by the call. What I heard was inappropriate, and I reported my concerns to Mr. Eisenberg. It is improper for the President of the United States to demand a foreign government investigate a US citizen and a political opponent.
我对那次通话感到担忧。我所听到的是不适当的，我向艾森伯格先生报告了我的担忧。美国总统要求外国政府调查美国公民和政治对手是不恰当的。
In his testimony, Vindman emphasized that he did not go public with these concerns, but reported them up the chain of command, as his job required, because they had national security implications. He was not hoping to put the President on a trial. There was somebody else, an intelligence official, who blew the whistle and made the phone call public.
在证词中，温德曼强调他没有公开这些担忧，而是按照工作要求向指挥链上层报告了它们，因为它们具有国家安全含义。他并不希望把总统送上审判。有另一个人，一名情报官员，举报了这件事并让电话公开了。
But it was Vindman who became the public face of all this, who testified in public at the impeachment hearings, wearing his medals and his uniform, and was probably the most dramatic testimony of the hearings. And there were consequences to that. Two days after Donald Trump beat the impeachment charges, he fired Vindman from his White House job. One of Trump's advisors told CNN that this was meant to send a message to anybody who might cross Trump.
但正是温德曼成了这一切的公众形象，他在弹劾听证会上穿着勋章和制服公开作证，这可能是听证会上最戏剧性的证词。这带来了后果。在唐纳德·特朗普赢得弹劾指控两天后，他解雇了温德曼的白宫工作。特朗普的一位顾问告诉CNN，这意味着向任何可能反对特朗普的人发出信息。
Though he is now out of the White House, Vindman was still a military officer, but apparently too hot a property for the military to give a serious job to. They offered this combat veteran, a multilingual expert who'd been coordinating all US policy on Ukraine, Russia, and former Soviet states, a job at an army museum that had not even opened yet. This is about as far from the action as you can get.
虽然他现在离开了白宫，但温德曼仍然是一名军官，但显然对军方来说太烫手了，无法给他安排一份严肃的工作。他们为这位战斗老兵，一位一直在协调美国对乌克兰、俄罗斯和前苏联国家所有政策的多语言专家，提供了一份甚至还没有开幕的陆军博物馆的工作。这离行动尽可能远。
Vindman decided to leave the military, start a new life. He moved with his wife, Rachel, and his daughter to Florida, to a big, pretty house with huge windows.
温德曼决定离开军队，开始新的生活。他和他的妻子雷切尔以及女儿搬到了佛罗里达，住进了一栋有着巨大窗户的大而漂亮的房子里。
Well, when you walk into our house, you walk into a very empty space. High ceilings-- that's why we have the echoes.
嗯，当你走进我们的房子时，你走进了一个非常空旷的空间。高高的天花板——这就是为什么我们有回声。
Literally has only dog beds in it. And we tallied 11 dog beds for three dogs across the house.
字面上只有狗床在里面。我们数了数，房子里有三只狗睡的11张狗床。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, this is a room where there would be living room furniture and curtains and stuff.
是的，这是一个房间，那里会有客厅家具和窗帘等等。
Yes. We have a plan for all of that, but we are not purchasing the furniture and the curtains, the window treatments, until we have a little bit more clarity on the election in November because I don't know what we're going to do. We don't have plans to leave. But if Donald Trump is re-elected--
是的。我们有这一切的计划，但我们不购买家具和窗帘、窗饰，直到我们对11月的选举有一点更明确的了解，因为我不知道我们将要做什么。我们没有离开的计划。但如果唐纳德·特朗普连任——
That sounds a little-- that, frankly, sounds a little bit alarmist. And I understand the idea that we need to save money in general just to make sure that-- contingencies, which is--
这听起来有点——这坦率地说，听起来有点危言耸听。而且我明白总的来说我们需要省钱的想法，只是为了确保——突发事件，这是——
Yeah, that's fair, contingencies. Your contingencies are different than my contingencies. I think we have a different calculus for how we calculate the danger.
是的，公平地说，突发事件。你的突发事件与我的突发事件不同。我认为我们在计算危险方面有不同的算法。
What's interesting talking to the Vindmans is that they do not agree on the danger they're in. It really drives home how nobody knows what Donald Trump's retribution is going to look like, who he's going to go after, or what he's going to try to do to them. So you have all these people guessing, like the Vindmans. Rachel's best guess is that they really might need to leave the country. Things might get that bad for them.
与温德曼一家交谈有趣的是，他们对他们所处的危险并不认同。这真的让人深刻体会到没有人知道唐纳德·特朗普的报应会是什么样子，他会去对付谁，或者他会试图对他们做什么。所以你有所有这些人猜来猜去，就像温德曼一家。雷切尔的最佳猜测是他们可能真的需要离开这个国家。对他们来说情况可能会变得那么糟。
Alex just doesn't see it. This is the country that gave his family refuge from authoritarianism. He arrived here at the age of four, after his dad fled the Soviet Union.
亚历克斯就是看不见。这是给他的家人提供避难所免受威权主义伤害的国家。在他父亲逃离苏联后，他在四岁时抵达这里。
You just can't imagine leaving the country.
你只是无法想象离开这个国家。
No, not possible. I think the fact is that I served a full military career to protect this country, and I'm not going to give it up.
不，不可能。我认为事实是我服完了完整的军旅生涯来保护这个国家，我不会放弃它。
He gestures around the living room.
他向客厅周围做手势。
Well, I would just say that Ali and I, our 13-year-old, have an ulterior motive here. And this is an ideal space to be able to--
好吧，我只想说阿里和我，我们的13岁，在这里有一个不可告人的动机。这是一个理想的空间，能够——
Can you please be serious?
你能不能认真一点？
Yes, to be able to play her VR because there's no impediments, you know--
是的，能够玩她的VR，因为没有任何障碍，你知道——
This is not the point of the story, OK?
这不是故事的重点，好吗？
When I ask them each, separately, to explain why they see whatever danger they might be in so differently, they each had the same answer-- temperament.
当我单独问他们每一个人为什么他们对可能所处的危险看法如此不同时，他们每一个都有同样的回答——气质。
Alex is exceedingly optimistic. It is a little annoying at times.
亚历克斯非常乐观。有时这有点烦人。
So I would revert to what my daughter says about us, which is that I'm responsible for fun, and Rachel is responsible for safety.
所以我将回到我女儿对我们的评价，那就是我负责乐趣，而雷切尔负责安全。
Hey, wait. Why does it work out that way? You're the military officer. How is she the safety one?
嘿，等等。为什么会那样？你是军官。怎么她是负责安全的那个？
Because I'm the fun one. I tend to be pretty optimistic and kind of on the happy-go-lucky side.
因为我是负责乐趣的那个。我倾向于相当乐观，有点乐天派的一面。
In person, at home, Alex Vindman is more boyish and funnier than the decorated officer you might have seen on TV, if you watched any of his congressional testimony. He's the one who will clown around for long stretches with the little nephews and nieces at the pool, doing cannonballs and riling them up. He's the one who thinks things will work out.
在家里，亚历克斯·温德曼比你在电视上可能看到的勋章军官更孩子气、更有趣，如果你看过他的任何国会证词的话。他是那个会在游泳池边和侄子侄女们玩很久，跳炸弹式跳水并逗弄他们的人。他是那个认为事情会好转的人。
She's the one who takes a grimmer view of their prospects. And that's how it's been from the beginning of the troubles with Donald Trump, going all the way back to the very first conversation about the Zelenskyy phone call and what it might mean for their family.
她是那个对他们的前景持悲观态度的人。从唐纳德·特朗普出现麻烦开始，情况就是这样，一直追溯到关于泽连斯基电话的第一次谈话，以及这对他们的家庭可能意味着什么。
That first conversation, they both say, happened when the news broke about that phone call. Rachel heard a story about the Trump-Zelenskyy call on NPR. And then that night, Alex brought it up with her, this thing in the news that obviously was something very close to his own job.
他们俩都说，第一次谈话发生在关于那个电话的新闻曝光时。雷切尔在NPR上听到了关于特朗普-泽连斯基通话的故事。然后那天晚上，亚历克斯和她提起了这件事，这件新闻里显然是非常接近他自己工作的事情。
And we were laying in bed, and he said, can you please call and check on professional liability insurance tomorrow? And he rolled over and went to sleep. And I was awake all night long.
我们躺在床上，他说，你明天能不能打电话查询一下职业责任保险？然后他翻身睡觉了。我彻夜未眠。
He wanted her to check on buying professional liability insurance to cover legal fees. The Vindmans were a couple who had to figure out how to deal with other hard stuff before this-- tough overseas postings, including three years in Moscow. They lost their first child, who was born four months early and died a week later. But this was something without any normal rulebook, testifying against a sitting president.
他想要她查询购买职业责任保险以支付法律费用。温德曼一家是一对不得不弄清楚在之前如何处理其他困难事情的夫妇——艰苦的海外驻扎，包括在莫斯科的三年。他们失去了他们的第一个孩子，那个孩子提前四个月出生，一周后死亡。但这是一种没有任何正常规则书的事情，作证反对一位在职总统。
And the way they dealt with the blowback seems to be they got very practical, tried to assess the risks and their options as clearly as they could. After Alex testified, he got called a traitor, a double agent who was working for Ukraine. They got doxxed, threatened, menacing letters were sent to their house, anti-Semitic slurs. It was frightening.
他们处理反冲的方式似乎是他们变得非常实际，试图尽可能清楚地评估风险和他们的选择。亚历克斯作证后，他被称为叛徒，为乌克兰工作的双重代理人。他们被肉搜、威胁，恐吓信被寄到他们家，反犹太主义的辱骂。这很令人恐惧。
But they were pragmatic about it-- got the Army to do a threat assessment, made arrangements to move to a military base if things got too severe. And this past year, they kept that risk assessment going, keeping an eye on the things that Donald Trump's been saying about retribution. When he's talking a lot about putting his enemies in jail, they did feel like, oh, that's us. And Alex's hackles raise any time Trump talks about the impeachment hoax or the phone call that he had with Zelenskyy back in July 2019.
但他们务实地对待它——让军队进行威胁评估，如果情况太严重，安排搬到军事基地。而在过去的一年里，他们保持了这种风险评估，关注唐纳德·特朗普一直在说的关于报应的事情。当他谈论很多关于把他的敌人关进监狱时，他们确实觉得，哦，那是我们。每当特朗普谈论“弹劾骗局”或者他在2019年7月与泽连斯基进行的电话时，亚历克斯就会恼火。
I mean, there was something I guess commented on just within the past week, where he claimed that it was a perfect phone call. Actually, I could pull it up here. Give me a second. OK, this was two days ago.
我的意思是，我想在过去一周内有一些评论，他声称那是一个完美的电话。实际上，我可以在这里调出来。给我一秒钟。好的，这是两天前。
So this is at his rally just two days ago in Dayton, Ohio, where he was talking about the fact that there was a video or audio tape of the phone call, July 25 phone call.
所以这是在两天前他在俄亥俄州代顿的集会上，他谈到了电话的事实，视频或音频磁带，7月25日的电话。
Shifty Adam Schiff. This is one of the most dishonest human beings.
狡猾的亚当·希夫。这是最不诚实的人类之一。
He's talking about the Democrat who ran the impeachment hearings, Adam Schiff.
他在谈论那个负责弹劾听证会的民主党人，亚当·希夫。
He made up my conversation that I had with the president of Ukraine. He made up the conversation. But here's what they didn't know. The phone call-- because it was a White House call, and for some reason, it happened to be on tape. So I let them go more and more. The stories got wilder and wilder. Then we released the tape. They died. They didn't know that phone call was taped. And they got caught.
他编造了我和乌克兰总统的谈话。他编造了谈话。但这是他们不知道的。电话——因为那是白宫电话，出于某种原因，它恰好录音了。所以我让他们继续下去。故事越来越离谱。然后我们发布了磁带。他们死了。他们不知道那个电话录音了。他们被抓住了。
Just in case there's any ambiguity in your mind right now, none of this is true. It's complete fantasy. There is no tape of the Zelenskyy phone call. The transcript we have comes from staff notes made during the call. So Trump did not release any tape of any sort and catch Schiff or anybody else in any lies.
以防你脑子里现在有任何歧义，这一切都不是真的。这是完全的幻想。没有泽连斯基电话的磁带。我们拥有的成绩单来自通话期间制作的员工笔记。所以特朗普没有发布任何磁带并抓住希夫或任何其他人的谎言。
He talks about these things all the time, in multiple venues. This was literally two days ago.
他在多个场合一直谈论这些事情。这实际上是两天前。
And so that tells you, you're still on his mind.
所以这告诉你，你还在他的心上。
Yeah, definitely still on his mind.
是的，绝对还在他的心上。
Alex and I talked about it. It was very chilling, I think, that he brought up the phone call. Because you'd like to think he moved on to other people that he hates-- Liz Cheney. I don't know-- I mean, any number of people. And he does talk about them, but that's still there. And I think he would absolutely seek retribution. So you'd like to think that we could fly under the radar for a little bit if things got bad, but I'm not so sure.
亚历克斯和我谈过这件事。我想他提起那个电话令人非常不寒而栗。因为你愿意认为他继续针对他恨的其他人——利兹·切尼。我不确定——我的意思是，任何数量的人。他确实谈论他们，但那仍然存在。我认为他绝对会寻求报应。所以你愿意认为如果情况变糟，我们能暂时低调飞行，但我不太确定。
If things did get bad, what did the Vindmans think retribution for them might look like from Donald Trump or the people around him? I asked them to rank from most likely to least likely. At the top of the list was some of the stuff other people told us. They'd try to take Alex's pension or entitlements, or maybe the president would direct the Department of Justice or the FBI to investigate Alex, and he'd have to hire a lawyer, which is a huge hassle, even if no conviction came from it.
如果情况变糟了，温德曼一家认为唐纳德·特朗普或他周围的人对他们的报应可能是什么样子的？我让他们按从最有可能到最不可能排名。名单之首是一些别人告诉我们的东西。他们会试图拿走亚历克斯的养老金或津贴，或者总统可能会指挥司法部或联邦调查局调查亚历克斯，他将不得不聘请律师，这是一个巨大的麻烦，即使没有从中得出定罪。
When I asked them about their most far-fetched fears, Rachel said she was hesitant to mention this next one because it's so out there. But she worries that Alex would be tried for treason, and the penalty could be death.
当我问他们关于他们最牵强的恐惧时，雷切尔说她很犹豫要不要提到接下来这个，因为它太遥远了。但她担心亚历克斯会被以叛国罪审判，惩罚可能是死刑。
Yeah, I don't want to seem like a nut, but if you just google or just do a search on Twitter or something-- what they want most of all is Alex to be arrested and tried for treason. They truly think that he went against his commander in chief, and that is an act of treason.
是的，我不想看起来像个疯子，但如果你只是在谷歌上或在推特上搜索一下——他们最想要的是亚历克斯被捕并以叛国罪审判。他们真的认为他反对了他的总司令，那是一种叛国行为。
That's what the MAGA people feel.
这就是MAGA人们的感觉。
Right, the MAGAs.
对了，MAGA。
His most far-fetched fear? Again, neither of them think these things are likely.
他最牵强的恐惧？再一次，他们俩都不认为这些事情是可能的。
I think about the fact that I'm an immigrant, and is there any chance that I could lose my citizenship as a naturalized citizen? And then I, frankly, don't have a country, frankly, because the Soviet Union doesn't exist. The Ukrainian Soviet Socialist Republic doesn't exist. So that idea has probably crossed my mind once or twice, that that would be a tougher thing to bear than even some of the prosecutions or something of that nature, that I would lose the fact that I'm an American.
我想到我是移民的事实，我作为归化公民是否有失去公民身份的机会？然后我坦率地说，我没有国家，坦率地说，因为苏联不存在了。乌克兰苏维埃社会主义共和国不存在了。所以那个想法可能在我的脑海中闪过一两次，那会比一些起诉或那种性质的事情更难承受，我将失去我是美国人的事实。
I don't want to read too much into this, but her worst fear is that he'd die, and his worst fear is not that he'd die, but that he would lose his country.
我不想在这个问题上想太多，但她最大的恐惧是他会死，而他最大的恐惧不是他会死，而是他会失去他的国家。
Back in the impeachment hearings, Vindman ended his prepared testimony by talking about his father, who he looks up to and who he's turned to for advice his whole life. His dad was a civil engineer, who had risen through the ranks and prospered in the old Soviet Union, couldn't stand the wrongdoing that he saw built into the system, and fled to start again at the bottom in America, at the age of 47.
回到弹劾听证会上，温德曼通过谈论他所尊敬并一生都寻求建议的父亲结束了他的准备好的证词。他的爸爸是一位土木工程师，他在旧苏联中晋升并繁荣起来，无法忍受他在系统中看到的错误，并逃离到美国，在47岁时从底部重新开始。
Not long before Alex testified in Congress, they were driving to a family wedding in Rhode Island, and Alex let his dad know that he might be pulled into the upcoming impeachment hearings
在亚历克斯在国会作证前不久，他们正开车去罗德岛参加一个家庭婚礼，亚历克斯让他的爸爸知道他可能会被卷入即将到来的弹劾听证会。
And that there was no way for me to avoid being drawn into this. And his counsel was, don't mess around with these people. They could wreck everything for you, derail your career and all that kind of stuff.
而且我没有办法避免被卷入其中。他的建议是，不要和这些人闹着玩。他们可以毁掉你的一切，让你的职业生涯脱轨，所有那种事情。
I was in the car. I was in the very back, and there was a lot of Russian. I understand Russian, but I don't speak it. But I could see them in the front. I mean, Alex's dad was yelling, and he was very upset.
我在车里。我在最后面，有很多俄语。我懂俄语，但我不会说。但我可以看到他们在前面。我的意思是，亚历克斯的爸爸在叫喊，他非常不安。
And his dad was saying?
而且他爸爸在说？
Don't testify. Don't testify against the most powerful man in the world. Don't do it. There's nothing to be gained for it. Don't do it.
不要作证。不要作证反对世界上最有权势的人。不要做。从中没有什么可得到的。不要做。
And he was actually more concerned about, like-- the Soviet context would be imprisoned, murdered, or things of that nature.
而且他实际上更关心，比如——苏联背景会被监禁、谋杀或那种性质的事情。
So he thought you could be imprisoned and murdered?
所以他认为你可能会被监禁和谋杀？
Well, I mean, we had lived in the US for 40 years, so he knows the US is different than the Soviet Union. But when you cross power, that kind of unchecked power with that kind of personality, that the consequences would be severe.
嗯，我的意思是，我们在美国生活了40年，所以他知道美国与苏联不同。但当你跨越权力，那种带有那种个性的不受约束的权力时，后果将是严重的。
At his testimony, Vindman nodded to that disagreement with his dad, talked about how in many countries, including Russia, raising concerns about the president's phone call, even privately in the chain of command, would have severe repercussions.
在作证时，温德曼向与他爸爸的分歧点头，谈到在许多国家，包括俄罗斯，提高对总统电话的担忧，即使是在指挥链中私下提高，也会有严重的后果。
And offering public testimony involving the president would surely cost me my life. Dad, I'm sitting here today in the US Capitol, talking to our elected professionals, is proof that you made the right decision 40 years ago to leave the Soviet Union and come here to the United States of America in search of a better life for our family. Do not worry. I will be fine for telling the truth.
而且提供涉及总统的公开证词肯定会让我付出生命。爸爸，我今天坐在美国国会大厦，与我们当选的专业人士谈话，是我40年前做出离开苏联来到这里的美利坚合众国寻求更好生活的正确决定的证明。不要担心。我会因为说真话而没事的。
Alex says that at the time that really seemed true to him, that he could testify without serious repercussions. But today?
亚历克斯说，在当时这对他来说似乎是真的，他可以在没有严重后果的情况下作证。但今天？
I'd say if we go into 2024 with Trump being reelected, I wouldn't have that kind of confidence going forward. I still have a lot of faith in this country, but if we do elect Trump a second time around, I'm not sure if right would still matter.
我会说如果我们进入2024年特朗普连任，我不会有那种信心。我对这个国家仍然有很大的信心，但如果我们确实再次选举特朗普，我不确定权利是否仍然重要。
Act Three, Four More Years. OK, so we've heard from a bunch of people who are dreading a second Trump term. What about the people who are excited about Trump winning, who've been gearing up for it? We wondered, is Donald Trump's desire for revenge something they share? Is this part of his pitch something they actually care about? Zoe Chace talked to a bunch of Trump voters before and after the guilty verdicts in his court case a week ago.
第三幕，再过四年。好了，我们已经听了一群担心第二个特朗普任期的人的声音。那些对特朗普获胜感到兴奋、一直在为此做准备的人呢？我们想知道，唐纳德·特朗普对复仇的渴望是他们分享的东西吗？他推销的这部分是他真正关心的事情吗？佐伊·蔡斯在特朗普案的一周前有罪判决前后与一群特朗普选民进行了交谈。
The first group of voters I talked to, they were at a Trump rally in Wildwood, New Jersey, literally on the boardwalk with arcade games. And today, a Justice for January 6 Prisoners tribute band.
我采访的第一群选民，他们在新泽西州怀尔德伍德的特朗普集会上，字面上是在有着街机游戏的木板路上。今天，有一个“1月6日囚犯正义”致敬乐队。
[BAND PLAYING "WE'RE NOT GONNA TAKE IT"]
[乐队演奏“我们不会再接受它”]
The line to get into the rally was on the beach, in the sand. The mood was upbeat. The music was classic. The vibe was relaxed and sunny, lots of families. I started talking to people, asking everyone, what are the top things you want from Trump if he's back in office, curious if they'd say revenge.
进入集会的队伍在海滩上，在沙子里。情绪乐观。音乐很经典。氛围轻松晴朗，许多家庭。我开始与人们交谈，询问每个人，如果他重返办公室你最想要特朗普做什么，好奇他们是否会说复仇。
Inflation to go down, lower inflation, gas prices, migrants, the borders closed.
通货膨胀下降，较低的通货膨胀，汽油价格，移民，边界关闭。
100% economy. I drive a pickup truck, and shit's getting expensive for me.
100%经济。我开一辆皮卡车，事情对我来说变得昂贵。
Lower rent, mortgage, that kind of thing.
较低的租金，抵押贷款，诸如此类。
I have a 28-year-old that's trying to buy a home, and we told them not even to bother to move out right now.
我有一个28岁的孩子正在试图买房，我们告诉他们现在甚至不要烦恼搬出去。
Just to bring things back to a normalcy, to bring fuel prices back. Just try to take it back to the way it was four years ago.
只是为了让事情恢复正常，让燃油价格回来。只是尝试把它带回四年前的样子。
Notice what never came up-- retribution. This is very obviously not a scientific sample, but still, out of about two dozen people, none of them mentioned it. I even brought up specific people who crossed Trump, like testified against him in the New York trial. And people were like, eh, I don't know.
注意什么从未出现——报应。这非常明显不是一个科学样本，但即便如此，在大约两打人中，他们没有人提到它。我甚至提到了冒犯特朗普的特定人物，比如在纽约审判中对他作证的人。人们就像，呃，我不知道。
You think that Trump, do you think he's going to go after Stormy Daniels or Michael Cohen, like punish them?
你认为特朗普，你认为他会去对付斯托米·丹尼尔斯或迈克尔·科恩吗，比如惩罚他们？
No.
不。
I don't think so.
我不这么认为。
I don't think so. I don't think--
我不这么认为。我不认为——
He gives two craps.
他给两个屁。
Really? Even though he--
真的吗？即使他——
No, of course, he probably hates them.
不，当然，他可能恨他们。
Right.
对。
But no, I think he has more important things to do.
但没有，我认为他有更重要的事情要做。
Exactly. Exactly. I think he's going to put it behind him, yes.
完全正确。完全正确。我认为他会把它抛在脑后，是的。
Do you think he's going to go after Biden? No, he's not. Biden is an old man. He's not going to live that much longer.
你认为他会去对付拜登吗？不，他不会。拜登是一个老头。他不会活那么久了。
I don't see retribution or revenge. He is for the people. He is for helping the people. That's what we need.
我没有看到报应或复仇。他是为了人民。他是为了帮助人民。这就是我们需要的东西。
When Trump started this campaign, something that he said was, I am your warrior. I am your justice. I am--
当特朗普开始这次竞选时，他说的一件事是，我就是你们的战士。我就是你们的正义。我就是——
Retribution. Retribution, right, was the word I think he used.
报应。报应，对吧，我想那是他用的词。
Yeah. What do you think if he does end up using the DOJ to go after his political enemies--
是的。如果你认为他最终利用司法部去对付他的政治敌人——
That's what they're doing. So now he knows how to do it. But he won't do that.
这就是他们正在做的。所以现在他知道怎么做了。但他不会那样做。
To everybody here, retribution isn't some hypothetical future thing to be afraid of. It's already here. It's happening now, under Biden. And Biden is the one using his Justice Department to persecute his political opponent. Six special prosecutors on him, sent the FBI to raid his house. There's no evidence any of that's true. These are all independent investigations, but people believe it.
对这里的所有人来说，报应不是某种需要害怕的假设未来事情。它已经在这里了。它现在正在发生，在拜登之下。拜登是那个利用他的司法部去迫害他的政治对手的人。六名特别检察官针对他，派联邦调查局去突袭他的房子。没有证据表明这一切是真的。这些都是独立的调查，但人们相信它。
So they have weaponized the DOJ. Look at Mar-a-Lago, the raid.
所以他们把司法部武器化了。看看海湖庄园，突袭。
You're like, the Justice Department is totally politicized.
你是说，司法部完全政治化了。
They got to go. They're using their power and authority. They're abusing their power and authority in order to silence this person because for whatever reason, they have so much hatred towards Donald Trump. And it's like, you hate him that much?
他们必须走。他们正在使用他们的权力和权威。他们正在滥用他们的权力和权威以便让这个人沉默，因为无论出于什么原因，他们对唐纳德·特朗普怀有如此多的仇恨。就像，你那么恨他吗？
Would you be comfortable with a president going after his political enemies, like using the DOJ and the--
你觉得总统利用司法部去对付他的政治敌人舒服吗，比如利用司法部和——
No, no. That's not what it's designed for. No. I wouldn't--
不，不。这不是为了它设计的。不。我不会——
I think that's what's happening to him. I don't think that's right.
我认为那就是正在发生在他身上的事。我不认为那是对的。
This brings me to something I want to draw your attention to, something very different from most of what you've heard this hour. A significant number of people in my unscientific sample told me they don't want Trump or anyone else to use the powers of the federal government to take down their political opponents. They want things the way they used to be. They want things back to normal.
这让我想到了我想要引起你们注意的事情，与你们这一小时听到的大部分内容非常不同。我非科学样本中的相当多的人告诉我，他们不想要特朗普或任何人利用联邦政府的权力去搞垮他们的政治对手。他们想要事情像过去一样。他们想要事情恢复正常。
Is there something that Trump could do with respect to going after his political enemies that would make you uncomfortable?
特朗普在去对付他的政治敌人方面可以做些什么让你感到不舒服？
If he did a witch hunt like we're going through right now.
如果他像我们现在经历的那样进行猎巫行动。
No witch hunt for witch hunt.
不以猎巫对猎巫。
Yeah, nope.
是的，不。
And what do you want Trump's Justice Department to look like?
而且你想要特朗普的司法部是什么样子的？
Well, you know what? I don't know, but maybe it should be nonpartisan.
嗯，你知道吗？我不知道，但也许它应该是无党派的。
It sounds like you don't want the Justice Department to be used by a president to go after their political enemies. And you kind of feel like that's what's happening now.
听起来你不想要司法部被总统用来对付他们的政治敌人。你有点觉得那正是现在正在发生的。
They did.
他们确实做了。
Free Trump! Free Trump! Free Trump! Free Trump! Free Trump!
自由特朗普！自由特朗普！自由特朗普！自由特朗普！自由特朗普！
You know what looked extra bad to Trump supporters? Trump getting convicted of 34 felonies in the middle of Manhattan by a bunch of people who probably didn't vote for him.
你知道什么对特朗普支持者来说看起来特别糟糕吗？特朗普被曼哈顿中间的一群可能没有投他票的人定罪34项重罪。
I ran over to Trump Tower the day after the verdict, where supporters were gathering to hear Trump speak, wondering if I was going to hear anything different at this fever pitch moment. I was mushed up against the glass of the Prada store with a bunch of people, asking, what about now, post-verdict? Should Trump use the government to punish his enemies at this point?
判决后的一天我跑到了特朗普大厦，那里支持者们聚集在一起听特朗普讲话，想知道我是否会在这个狂热的时刻听到任何不同的东西。我挤在普拉达商店的玻璃窗上，和一群人在一起，问，现在怎么样，判决后？特朗普现在应该利用政府来惩罚他的敌人吗？
Do you feel excited about the idea of revenge or retribution?
你对复仇或报应的想法感到兴奋吗？
See, when he's saying that, it's not like revenge that I'm going to go out and kill people or beat people, put them in jail. It's to stop the deep state and stop corruption.
看，当他说那个时，不像是我要出去杀人或打人，把他们关进监狱那样的复仇。那是为了停止深层政府和停止腐败。
In a way, you think of it as making things fairer?
在某种程度上，你认为它是为了让事情变得更公平？
Yes.
是的。
Not like an eye for an eye. OK, so what would you think, though, if Trump did use the levers of the federal government to go after his political opposition?
不像以眼还眼。好了，那么，如果你认为特朗普确实利用联邦政府的杠杆去对付他的政治反对派，你会怎么想？
He won't. He won't.
他不会。他不会。
Even though he has said he would?
即使他说他会？
Not in the context that you're saying.
不在你所说的语境下。
OK.
好的。
That guy was from the Bronx, but another guy I met had flown in from Indiana to support Trump during the trial. That's passion.
那个家伙来自布朗克斯，但我认识的另一个人从印第安纳州飞过来在审判期间支持特朗普。那是激情。
Would you be comfortable with Trump using the levers of the federal government against his political enemies? Like, he's talked about going after the Biden crime family, or he's talked about going after the radical AGs, radical prosecutors. Would you be comfortable with that coming from him?
你觉得特朗普利用联邦政府的杠杆去对付他的政治敌人舒服吗？比如，他谈到去对付拜登犯罪家族，或者他谈到去对付激进的检察长、激进的检察官。你觉得那样从他那里来舒服吗？
No, my preference would be that as soon as Donald Trump is inaugurated as the 47th president that he pardons himself and he pardons Joe Biden.
不，我的偏好是，一旦唐纳德·特朗普作为第47任总统就职，他就赦免自己，他也赦免乔·拜登。
Well, Joe Biden's not on trial right now.
好吧，乔·拜登现在没有受审。
No, he's not on trial now. But I would like him to issue a pardon for the crimes that he has done, rather than prosecuting him, so that no one could prosecute him.
不，他现在没有受审。但我希望他发布一项赦免，为了他所做的罪行，而不是起诉他，这样就没有人能起诉他了。
I see. If Trump becomes president, you just want to move on.
我明白了。如果特朗普成为总统，你只是想继续前进。
Yes.
是的。
Retribution doesn't seem to be motivating these Trump voters as much as it's motivating Trump himself. But if it's not turning them away-- it sure doesn't seem to be-- then he has a good chance of getting into the White House. If he gets there, it won't really matter what was driving the voters. He'll be able to do whatever he wants.
报应似乎没有像激励特朗普本人那样激励这些特朗普选民。但如果它没有让他们离开——它看起来确实没有——那么他有很好的机会进入白宫。如果他到达那里，那是什么在驱动选民将不会真正重要。他将能够做他想做的任何事。
Zoe Chace is a producer on our show.
佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制作人。
Today's program was produced by Alix Spiegel and edited by Alix and me and Laura Starcheski and Bethel Habte. The people who put together today's episode include Chris Benderev, Phia Bennin, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKorenfeld, Seth Lind, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Safiyah Riddle, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our Managing Editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our Senior Editor is David Kestenbaum. Our Executive Editor is Emanuele Berry.
今天的节目由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔制作，由阿利克斯、我、劳拉·斯塔切斯基和贝瑟尔·哈布特编辑。今天制作本集的人包括克里斯·本德雷夫、菲亚·本宁、肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、阿维瓦·德科伦费尔德、赛斯·林德、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、萨菲亚·里德尔、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-特克斯托、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks today to Mark Zaid, Eugene and Cindy Vindman, Jennifer Jacobsen, Jennifer Weaver, James Sherk, Ellen Wittman, Stephen Bradbury, Kelefa Sanneh, Ryan Gidursky, and Sarah Isghur. Washington Post reporter Isaac Arnsdorf, who you heard at the top of the show, wrote a great book about Trump's followers called Finish What We Started.
今天特别感谢马克·扎伊德、尤金和辛迪·温德曼、詹妮弗·雅各布森、詹妮弗·韦弗、詹姆斯·谢尔克、艾伦·威特曼、斯蒂芬·布拉德伯里、凯莱法·桑内、瑞安·吉德斯基和莎拉·伊斯古尔。《华盛顿邮报》记者艾萨克·阿恩斯多夫，你在节目开头听到的，写了一本关于特朗普追随者的伟大的书，书名是《完成我们开始的事》。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. If you are needing something to listen to, you don't know what to do while you're doing a thing, you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He is constantly asking me this about the host of The Daily, Michael Barbaro.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。如果你需要听什么，你不知道你在做事情时该做什么，你可以完全免费流媒体播放我们超过800集的档案，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他一直在问我关于《每日》的主持人迈克尔·巴巴罗的事。
Who do you think is the biggest killer-- this guy or President Xi of China?
你认为谁是最大的杀人犯——这家伙还是中国的习主席？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[CLOSING SONG]
[结束歌曲]